all right so we have yin ying had run a
total of 30 laps for a running class or
running club i should say so ying ying
ran a total of 30 laps
then ying ying ran four more laps before
his school so she ran four more laps
before school three more laps at lunch
three more laps at lunch and two more
laps at recess eating's doing a lot of
running
two more laps at recess so what i want
to do is i want to figure out the total
number of laps that ying ying ran and
i'm going to do it using a number line
so let's draw a number line here
let's draw a number line
and yinging starts at 30 laps she'd run
30 laps and then she keeps reading she
keeps running more laps than that so my
number line i could start it wherever i
want but it might be convenient to start
it at 30 and it obviously could i could
do it at 29
and then i could go 30. actually let me
just keep going up from there 31
a few more left 36
whoops 38
and let's say
40 and i could go all the way to 41
that's how much space i have so let's
see ying ying started at 30 laps
so she started at 30 laps
for a running club
then she ran ying ying your aunt four
more laps before school so on the number
line if i go four more that's going to
be to the right i'm going to be
increasing by four so i'm going to be
increasing by one two three four so
those four laps before school take us
from 30 to 34.
then she runs three more laps at lunch
so then from the 34 she's gonna go one
two three to 37.
it's gonna go to 37.
so that's what those three more laps at
lunch do for us and then two more laps
at recess
so she was at 37 and now we're gonna go
one two
to thirty nine
so how many total laps does ying ying
run
well ying ying runs a total of 39 laps
39 laps and we were able to figure it
out using this number line
now let's do a an exercise very similar
to this that you might see on khan
academy
so this one right over here actually let
me get rid of the stuff about yin ying
so we don't get confused
so this says and it's a little bit
smaller but hopefully you can see what
it says a red ant army started with 100
started with 100 marching ants so we're
going to start with 100 and actually
they tell us well let me just read the
whole thing started with 100 marching
ants then the red army
lost three ants down a hole so actually
let me let me get so lost three ants
down a hole
three ants were eaten by a bird that's
unfortunate
and one ant just blew away i guess ants
are fairly light creatures so that makes
sense
one ant blew away which number line
shows how to find how many ants the red
army has left
well the army started with 100 marching
ants we underlined that over here so we
need to start with 100 so we just start
with 100
this one starts with 10. so i can
immediately rule this one out
and so we could just
we could just select that one but let's
just make sure it makes sense so we
start with 100
and then we lose three ants down a hole
so we're gonna go down remember we're
losing ants so we're gonna go to the
left of the number line we're gonna go
to lower values we're gonna go down one
two three
so these are the three ants we lose down
a hole so three down the hole
then we have three that were eaten by a
bird so you're going to lose three more
that's those three right over there gets
to 94 ants left and then we have the one
ant that gets blown away so that gets us
down to 93 ants left so the red army or
the red ant army has
93 ants left
ants left and we are done